foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining our improving develop
productivity and security with
cloud-based development environment
thanks everybody for joining I'm Marcus
product manager within Google Cloud
developer experience organization
specifically focused on cloud
workstations and I'm joined today by
Christian hi everyone I am Christian
guaca I'm from Commerce Bank from
Germany and I'm heading to cyber Center
for excellence team in comets Bank I'm
proud to join the session for Marcus
all right so agenda for today right so
we start by giving folks a high level
review of what is caloric stations what
problem it Services then we move on to
the Rainy product Deep dive talk a bit
about the features both existing and new
features introduced and finally a
question we talked a bit more about the
Commerce Bank story and journey when
adopting workstations at scale right so
let's start okay so Clorox stations
overview right so the key idea here is
let's first talk about recapping all the
tools Google cloud has currently
available for uh developers right so you
can see here a list of those tools
essentially the first of them was a
cloud shell so Cloud shell essentially
provides you with a pre-configured
development environment available from a
terminal the dahu is a development
environment which is focused on
simplifying onboarding and evaluation
let's say you want to run a gcloud
command or want to quickly set up pgk
cluster did you hear you just go to a
browser either on the cloud console or
the Standalone cloud share and within a
few seconds you're up and running and
getting some basic prototypes working
next we also have Cloud code the idea
here are ID extensions you can install
on your preferred ID be it Visual Studio
code be it IntelliJ pycharm the idea
here is helping you while you're
developing against Google Cloud let's
say imagine kubernetes development on
gke cloudron development and so on and
so forth right so let's uh three years
ago we announced a major update to a
cloud shell editor essential using
capabilities such as debugging and
troubleshooting and versioning did you
hear was also make it easier for tasks
which are Developer specifics such as I
want to try an API Google cloud or
quickly get a basic web server up and
running from a configure environment
this year at Google I O early the zero
announced the ga of cloud Rec stations
which will be essentially covering in
depth uh today you can see essentially
workstations being the dev environment
which goes beyond onboarding that's the
environment which is tailored for
day-to-day development imagine you've
been able to customize a environment
with the libraries and the tools you
need for your day-to-day development
and finally also today you folks saw
about some of the new expansions we had
on the private preview on the duet site
the key idea of duet is bringing
developer assistance directly on your ID
the true Focus here is one enabling
productivity for example as developer
you do more with less less time less
context switching less efforts and also
enablement and empowerment let's say as
developer can now do things which should
be otherwise a bit Out Of Reach or
potentially beyond your uh either
because you're too time consuming or a
bit above your technical uh punch weight
essentially by helping you with a
companion EI available either via a
chatbot or via a chat either via chatbot
or via contextual code generation right
so with that overview let me then dive
deeper into Clorox stations itself right
so you can see here a screenshot of what
it looks like the key idea of
workstations is essentially providing a
non-demand development environment
available from any machine you want to
use here right so the key idea here is
uh
it's a fully customizable development
environment the idea is yes you get a
code editor like we're seeing here but
also get all the layers of the stack you
need for your day-to-day development
such as you can specify ID extensions
the libraries the compute the storage
GPU accelerators network connectivity
essentially everything for you to have
this fully packaged ready to go
developer experience right so that's one
thing another key Focus here is
consistency among developer development
environments the idea here is with
workstations you can define a golden
workstation configuration which is
consistent across your developers let's
say if you are a team working on Java
with a jdk in Spring you can have all
these tools pre-installed and ready for
them to use from workstations right and
the final one here is all of this is
built with security mind the idea here
is uh as you folks you see here I also
do that while having a series of
compliance security and data
exfiltration mechanisms but in so that
you can have an improved developer
experience without sacrificing your
security in the process
so just a quick thing here is you saw
now what workstations is let me talk
quickly about the three key problems we
heard from many customers like Commerce
Bank and others that we believe
workstations as well suited uh to
address right so the first one is Dev
environment setup right that's one thing
which we hear time and time again that
it may take days weeks in some extreme
cases even months for a developer to be
able to get you hey I can read write
code and submit pull requests and a good
checkup this time it just spent it
during a development environment setup
you're starting to write dependencies so
on so forth that's one task which
workstations was really to address by
having this consistent environments the
second one here is a security and
exfiltration prevention right so the
moment you have your code and data
living on a local machine you're by
Design increasing your potential attack
surface the idea here is if you move
this code and data to a work through
environment which is cloud-based you not
only you minimize your attack service
but also open up the possibility of
using some of the security controls that
we talk later such as vpcsc Beyond Corp
Enterprise and so on so forth right and
finally but not least developer
productivity the key idea here is
something you saw for example was
challenges with accessing a resource on
a uh on a private Network all of those
are essentially kind of things which
typically it's hard kind of hard to find
a balance between velocity and security
that's workstation from The Sweet Spot
where you can have pre-configuring
environments while following the
organization and security policies as
well as more flexible compute and the
benefits of networking at higher higher
velocity network access for handling uh
artifacts right
so with that said that was the high
level review workstations let me now do
a per feature Deep dive for our focus on
each of these three problem spaces I
mentioned uh before right so
the first one here is development
environments uh fast onboarding with
developing environments ready to go here
right so folks can see here a video
essentially showing the creation of a
cloud Rec stations the idea here is
within a few minutes
you can get the development environment
up and running the idea here as you can
see here is as a developer I have a
choice of configurations those
configurations can be created by Central
platform team in updated here is a peak
one configuration once I click on start
you see here within a few seconds
I get a workstation up and running and
what happened here behind the scenes is
created evm we attached an image with
the customization of the developer needs
plus we mounted the persistent disk and
this process actually happens faster
because you have the keyboard support
for a pool of form VMS to essentially
allow this 30 seconds to uh writing code
experience here inside SMH before you
can see in that case we are showing a vs
code in the browser you can see our
extension potentially having a series of
code samples another case you can see a
bunch of java code but it could as well
be for example your private
microservices or some internal code you
have here and it also comes with
extensions and tools pre-install right
so if you hear open a basic Java file
you see you've got LinkedIn you get all
the Java extensions capabilities
pre-installed plus it comes with the
right version of the jdk pre-start and
all the Java libraries needed here right
so the idea here is having this set up
pre-baked and defined in a central
manner by platform teams right
that's it next one is GPU acceleration
right so uh one thing which I decided to
mention now is we have GPU acceleration
support within Cloud Rec stations
covering essentially a100s t4s h100s all
the most popular uh gpus available on
gcp and this essentially allows your
developers even either if they're
working on vs code pycharm Jupiter lab
or rstudio to be able to benefit from
GPU accelerations for uh machine
learning tests or data science specific
tasks right without having to worry
about setting up gpus or in about Cuda
driver setup for being productive
next one is region support right sir we
are very excited to hear about the
global interests we'll be getting on
cloud workstations our team is working
very hard at adding extending our region
support we're excited to see in our pet
training region supported across five
different four sorry four different
continents with uh Italy
Israel and Australia been in regions
which you just added over the last uh
months and many more to come as well
all right now shifting gears to
productivity right so let's talk about
the capabilities available for improving
uh developer productivity during the
keynote uh this morning folks heard
about duet in Google cloud and folks can
know that duet comes pre-installed on
our Cloud workstations essential you can
do here is once you sign up to duet on
that link and have here you can
essentially enable duet for development
teams what you see is essentially
something similar to what you're seeing
here on the screen essentially once you
enable duet you'll be able to get code
completions code Generations as well as
a contextual chat assistance which is
very helpful for tests such as code
explainability or test generation or for
example troubleshooting of echo it's a
very interesting side-by-side companion
the chatbot as well is aware of all the
files that have opened within your ID so
here you can say hey explain me my code
or explain me what these three functions
do you don't have to worry about having
to match exactly the signature of the
functions you have with between your
code and you also have this feature
smart actions essentially whenever you
select code within a cloudwork stations
when you have duet enabled you see the
option of contextual action such as
generating code in case you're selecting
common string or a dog string
or explaining code or generating unit
tests or generating doc strings right so
and again if folks want to trade out you
can go to cloud.google.com
AI to join our preview
for next slide I'll talk a bit about our
studio and posit workbench right so you
heard from many uh R and python
developers and data scientists that they
really like using the end-to-end
experience which posit workbench
provides them as such integrating code
editor and all the elements of the
devops of the software development life
cycle uh they need so a mixer channels
our partnership with a posit workbench
now in GA in cleric stations essentially
providing managed support for posit
workbench with rstudio including support
for for bringing your own license yeah
here you can now use your own licenses
for using posit in addition to the other
tools and IDs available within Cloud Rec
stations in a managed setting
and I then welcome posit to our family
of IDs supported in cloudwork stations
and workstations was built with a core
principle in mind which is be meeting
developers whatever they are right so we
know developers have a myriad of uh
tools that were selected over time to
optimize for the productivity our idea
here is to allow developers to
experience the benefit of remote
development and cloud-based environments
without requiring changes to workflows
so you can see here this light is
essentially showing many of the idea
support such as vs code IntelliJ Gallery
studio with many more on the pipeline on
our side right
finally Beyond IDs workstation or
support some additional interfaces which
come in handy on the development life
cycle for example as you can see here
you can use IntelliJ can access a
workstation via our local IntelliJ
viajet Prince Gateway
you can for example if you prefer using
local vs code you can use your local vs
code and use remote SSH being able to
access your extension via a secure SSH
tunnel which is enforced with gcp IEM
policies so the idea here is you can
have the best of both words essentially
the local development experience while
you're being able to benefit from a
remote machine and the security and
compute power it could provide you and
you can even set up SSH or even TCP
tunnels from the workstation to local
machine and you can see how this could
be handy for more complex
troubleshooting in a web server kind of
either troubleshooting or development
web server kind of setups right
now shifting gears I want to talk a bit
about security and direct filtration
mechanisms delicitation prevention
mechanisms right so first I want to talk
a bit about our integration with Beyond
Corp Enterprise right that's something
which we announced at Google I O early
this year and you continue to work on
extended this further the idea here is
bringing zero trust security mechanisms
directly to your development
environments right so there are two
specific features I want to highlight
here the first one is data loss
protection you can actually see that on
the recording here that yeah here is you
can essentially enforce policies to
prevent uh to mitigate data loss
directly on your clients such as
limiting copy and paste of text or
download of files either blanket
policies or policies matching specific
string patterns so you can say Hey you
can block access to only to sensitive
pieces of code but allow access to other
piece of code that's one and two is
context our axis
right so cloudy stations also supports
the ability for you to set up access
policies which are take into account uh
context aware factors such as your IEP
location whether device is secured or
has specific software installed or
depending on your geolocation of devices
that yeah here is providing additional
layers of security you can pick and
choose to add to meet your security
postures right
next thing shared VPC support right so
one thing I want to highlight here which
is a very important point of
workstations is a workstation is
essentially a managed service which
provides environments essentially VMS
running containers inside of VPC
workstations using VM is the important
point we don't use
containers or pods as a security
boundary because they're known to have
potential excitation virtuality here is
having each developer having a separate
environment mitigates potential risk of
lateral contamination of those
environments the case of a next
situation plus our workstations run
inside of your you can choose to run
those Insider for VPC which allows you
to then bring the typical security
mechanisms used for your workloads for
your production workloads such as VPC
service controls or we can potentially
even say create a disk backup policies
let's say you want to have a weekly
pipeline to back up the date on your
disks for sale potentially auditing
purposes
and uh that's it for this one
and finally one here is for platform
admins we've been expanding the amount
of services workstations uh can be you
the amount of services you can use for
managing your Cloud workstations right
so the key idea here is yes we have the
typical Cloud console NG cloud services
but increasingly hearing about customers
wanting to use let's say terraform or
KCC other services for orchestrian
direct stations that yeah here is you
can now use terraform as folks can see
here or apis Focus trainer extensions
essentially using the same recipes and
plumbing you have for your order
production resources and you can create
your Dev environments the same with your
380r production environments right
folks that's it at a high level now hand
over for to Christian to talk a bit more
about their Journey on cloud
workstations yeah
great thank you very much Marcos I guess
this was very interesting until here and
um I will hope I hopefully can can
continue and I will talk a little bit
about Commerce Bank and how we are going
to leverage uh cloudworks and what we
are also doing as of today with Cloud
workstations so first of all
um I want to introduce you a little bit
to comments bank because you maybe don't
don't know what we are doing so comments
Bank
um has around 26 000 corporate client
customers and just under 11 million
private and small business customers in
Germany and uh comments bank is the
leading bank for the John middlestone so
this means we have a portfolio of
customers for corporate corporate
clients and for the private and small
medium businesses
furthermore we have a focus on five
business models so our business model is
structured into five elements one is the
personal advisory offering so meaning
for us the customer is always in the
focus and so we want to be the best
partner for our customer next is a
consistent customer focus so the changes
the demand of the customer and the the
wishes of the customer changes so we
need to adapt Nexus of course
comprehensive digitalization so this is
one part of why we why I'm here today is
because we are offering more and more
services on a digital level and
um
same goes for portfolio which we bring
to to a digital world the next uh
profitable profitability before growth
so this means that we need to focus on
the on the customer and for us again the
focus is customer and customer only and
last but not least sustainability which
is an important topic for us not only
for providing Sustainable Solutions but
also helping our customers to transition
in sustainable strategies
so the next we have comments back and
within comets Bank there are many
different divisions one of this division
is Big Data and advanced Analytics
um this is the division I'm I'm working
in and I just want to give you a brief
glance at what what we're doing how we
could characterize us so we are roughly
500 people uh spread across four
countries and we love being Pioneers So
within comets Bank we have been the
first area in in public cloud and
um we value Partnerships so meaning
within the cloud we have got very good
feedback from other key areas from other
divisions telling us hey what you're
doing is good and actually we we like to
partner with you
and what's actually quite interesting
and what I want to highlight today is
this one point is we also Drive
Innovation and what we are doing since
we started working on public cloud and
what we're doing until today is um
actually we're working closely together
with Google and we are also influencing
the Google Cloud source code so we have
contributed some lines to the to the
source code of Google Cloud so when
you're using something with security or
with containers there's a likelihood
that you're using actually some code
which came originally originally from
from commence Bank
so and of course we have a priority of a
diverse
a membership of employees and we we also
drive with developing new new talents
and last but not least we aim for a
dynamic mindset to grow furthermore
and to give you some examples from a
business point of view what we are doing
so baa creates value from data this
means we are gathering data from from
all of comets Bank we may be making it
accessible to other teams in combats
bank and possibly also outside of
comments bank and we offer several
services to it so meaning how to consume
data and how to get insights out of the
data and how to work with the data so we
are also providing tools for our
customers in the bank and outside of the
bank to process the data
and last but not least what's maybe the
the most difficult part here what will
also then connect to Cloud workstation
is the Innovation part together with a
regulatory part
because why we can do all this great
stuff we also need to to make sure that
we adhere to the regulations which apply
to us
and so to give you two examples of the
use case business use case we are doing
in in BDA is first electronical
self-disclosure so this is like applying
Ai and machine learning to
um to transaction data to classify them
and the second example is something we
call press for today so we are scanning
the news everyone can see and and and
apply the knowledge we gained from this
news to reach out to our customers and
connect these customers with a
relationship of the bank
and now we're coming slowly back to to
Cloud workstations
um finally this is my team cyber Center
of Excellence so we are doing three
things first is data protection so
making sure that we have the Legal
Foundation to process data
second is information security so all of
confidentiality Integrity availability
of data and processes and third last but
not least Cloud mainly public cloud and
within Cloud again there are three
things we are doing first is we are
taking care of use cases bringing use
case to the cloud so the two examples I
just mentioned like press for today or
electronical theft disclosure we help
this use case migrate to the cloud
and during this journey on the cloud we
also develop something something what we
call the cloud Enterprise Suite because
the cloud we don't only want to have
secure we also want to have it
trustworthy and this means whenever we
bring a use case to the cloud we make
sure that problems resolved once we only
solve really once and then have products
ready for next use case to come and this
is just the suit suit that we that we
built and on this journey of course we
also have to make sure we we take the
culture with us the people with us so we
also have something which we call the E
equals MC squared program which means we
we want to get the excitement into our
colleagues making sure that we multiply
our knowledge with spark curiosity and
of course Drive the the culture forward
and now the next question is okay now we
have learned a little bit about comets
Bank about big data and advanced
analytics about the Cyber Center of
Excellence but why should we choose
Cloud workstations well we had one
simple situation we found ourselves in
This was um our developers and analysts
um came to us and said hey we need an
easy solution to create Solutions on the
cloud
next we have local IDs yes but they are
not made for You Know Rich targets and
endpoints in the cloud and the last
situation that we faced was um
developers did actually take care of
their local machines in stores after
their installed packages and from these
situations we derived three challenges
the first key challenge is how can we
provide an IDE that is that has access
to Cloud
and on-prem CSD at the same time
next how can we make sure that we
provide all the software that is
required for developers to actually
develop new software or to do data
analytics and how can we avoid the issue
it works on my machine but not on
another else computer
and last but not least but also Marcos
touched was how can we decrease the
setup time from maybe weeks or months
down to maybe below a minute
and the resolution was actually Cloud
workstations
and Cloud workstations allows up to set
up as we have seen in the in the video
for Marcos set up an environment for a
developer who joins us today at the same
day at the same hour in the same minute
and thanks to that
um goes to it goes a little bit
um yeah prepared work that we did what
was that we connected cloudworks
stations to our on-prem CSD environment
making sure that we install everything
that is required from our point of view
that is legally allowed
and on the end which works perfectly in
the cloud
um
and next we do not only look at the
developers and elders but we also have
to look at the administrators who make
sure that what the developers are using
is actually a compliant a b can be
managed in a central place and this is
also something which was enabled by
Cloud workstations
and something which is often overlooked
but what I want to highlight here is
also um the cost model the cost is very
transparent and this pay as you go the
moment the developer shuts down its own
computer his own computer her own
computer in front of him or her the
clouds workstation will also be shut
down some minutes after and you can see
this in the costs you can see this in in
the management and this is just a nice
and handy feature to make sure we know
what we have to pay for
and um as Marcus also highlighted there
are three things I also want to Deep
dive into one is security how can we
make Cloud workstation secure second is
customization we have talked about
security but how can we marry this with
customization and last but not least
integration how can we integrate Cloud
workstations into Commerce bank's cicd
world
so let me first start with security so
especially within Financial institutes
you have a lot of regulations to follow
you have in-house regulations you have
regulations in Germany which are quite
restricted you have regulations in
Europe like the gdpr I guess there's
something similar here in California
with a ccsa and of course you have
Global regulations and comets Bank
acting as a global Institute financial
institute we have to adhere to all of
these regulations at the same time
so this means we need to make sure a we
have control over our Network this is
where the VPC service where the VPC
feature of cloud workstations come in
handy we need to make sure that the data
only flows where we want to control it
away we want to flow it
next which is very important for us is
customer encryption keys so whatever we
put on these Cloud workstations we need
to make sure it is encrypted our under
our key it is great that Marcos is
encrypting everything by by default but
we want to keep it secure under comments
bank's key
next we want to apply VPC service
control so when we use cloud
workstations with other servers on
Google cloud like let's say cloud build
we want to make sure that the data only
flows to that certain specific Cloud
build and not to any Cloud builds maybe
in a private project
access sheer record analyzation so when
we develop code when we develop new
environments we need to make sure that
this stays there where the regulator
wants to stay it that's mostly Europe
that's maybe Germany that's maybe the
Netherlands
next we want to make sure that every
application we use in the bank has some
certain industry security certifications
so like ISO 27001 or psic5 you name it
and this is also fulfilled by Cloud
workstations and the list goes on we
have service level agreements where we
have a certain amount of uptime we have
asset inventory where we can see how
many Cloud workstations we have who is
using which Cloud workstation how long
we have logging of course we have
monitoring of the cloud workstations
with identity control
we have to manage the IDE where you have
seen the plethora of different Ides that
you can have like rstudio or Visual
Studio code and all of this together is
actually what what makes Cloud
workstations a good security fit for us
because actually if you look at this
this list it looks like really a really
really long list but I can assure you
that we need to check area of these
boxes before we can run Cloud
workstations or any other servers and we
work together closely with Marcus to
make sure before we run the first
productive workload on on the cloud
workstations that the checkbox has made
but now we have talked about security
and access okay now we are we have a
quite secure boundary but how can we
customize it such that we can actually
serve our developers and the first thing
that we that we did is we looked here
how what what is actually needed we
asked our developers what do you want
and this was the first experience to our
developers usually they get served what
they want
um because this is just how things have
been and now we start we thought okay if
we start new then maybe here's this new
tool Cloud workstation how can we make
sure the developers feel home and get
the tools that they need and so we we
want to make sure that we have package
ready for them we want to have the IDE
they want to work in with we want to
make sure it's a programming language
they need to work to work with same goes
for packages containers
and then we also have certain uh let's
say groups of people working with it
some need gpus like those are which are
closer to to processing data then others
which need a lot of CPU and and RAM
which which need to to store a lot of
data and so we came up with personas and
actually we have we have templated this
into four different categories and you
see it on the on the right hand side of
the screen so we take Cloud workstations
we have a set of Administrators making
sure that we only have a certain set of
templates and then people can select out
of a certain set of templates which
configuration they need so we have
actually two groups we have developers
and data scientists with two completely
different usage profiles the developer
wants to to to to write code maybe wants
to use test data and this is something
which what we call the test box part of
of our Enterprise Suite I mentioned
earlier and there's just one button they
click they say hey I want to have a test
box they click on it and guess what two
minutes later or maybe even one minute
later they have everything ready they
have their own project they have their
own cloud workstation they have their
own bigquery and all of their their
their home filled environment in order
to start with
same with the data scientists data
scientist doesn't want to work with with
test data because they want to build
machine learning models which works
usually compared with with synthesized
data or at least with test data so they
need access to productive data so this
is a different workflow and a different
tooling they need but there's no problem
to it because we can customize Cloud
workstations in the security framework
to serve both types of Developers
and the third point and last Point as a
deep Drive is the integration how can we
make sure that the cloud workstation is
integrated in an existing environment in
at combat spring
so um we then built a cloud native CSD
Pipeline with mbdaa and we made sure
that we have the connectivity first to
our git to our on-prem git environment
because this is where the code lies next
we are connected to our on-prem
um repositories for the containers at
libraries and last but not least we also
have connected it to to Cloud build then
to further stage in the in the CSD
Pipeline and now the interesting part
here is that it is not only connected to
on-prem but it is also connected to new
security tools such as Azure open source
software where we can use libraries that
have been checked by by Google
um and then which feeds into our into
our library management system same goes
for container scanning which would use
artifact container for and make sure
that that everything flows together in
Cloud workstations and that the
developers and analysts only have one
point of contact which is the analytics
which is the customer
endpoint in the in the cloud workstation
and of course what was announced what
you might have seen this morning is
Druid AI for cloud workstations and this
is also something we are testing right
now and uh we're looking very much
forward to the to the features coming
and um it's a lot of fun working with
these new tools and and a huge gain of
um of productivity
and I also want to show you an example
how we used Cloud workstations in a
day-to-day use case so one example is
ESG or short for environment
environmental social and governmental
data
so we have a bdaa use case which is just
called ESG and there was one goal the
goal was to process ESG data for risk
evaluation within one month
and the tasks brought to us to ccoe was
a
provide use case lifecycle for the use
case on gcp
second enable the developers as fast as
possible and third ensure that the
architecture everything is working with
Cloud native
and so we started working and after some
some uh some days we actually had the
solution in our pockets first we
provided a use case specific Cloud
workstation setup
within a day
then on the second day we talked to the
developers and said hey look
everything's online you just need to
click this button and you can start
actually working and so already on day
two when the project started the
developers were available and ready to
use the cloud workstation connected to
on-prem to all the usual CSD flaws that
we have
and and started working and due to this
quick setup phase and due to the other
um Cloud native architecture with Cloud
functions with cloud storage with Pub
sub and all of that we made sure that
actually the goal of the use case to
provide this risk evaluation within one
month was achieved way earlier and um so
this is a good example I guess where you
can see that if you use the right tools
for the right problems you can make sure
that you actually achieve your goals and
at the end have a lot of time also left
for you know partying or doing the next
project
and I want to also I have I have
gathered some quotes here I just want to
share with you because remarkably for
this project was that within baa when we
brought and introduced Cloud
workstations to to our developers we got
a lot of very good feedback so nine of
out of 10 developers actually
recommended Cloud workstations to their
next developers who then approached us
and so we had this Avalanche effect of
developers actually knocking on our door
and saying hey I also want to test Cloud
workstations can I get to the beta
program and um in the end this led to to
developers analysts and admins been
actually very happy so um we have the
adminants who say that hey we have a
minimized infrastructure to manage
that's great the analyst said it's a
great responsiveness I can use Jupiter
notebook directly on on my browser
that's great and the developer said hey
it's a nice integration directly into
Google Cloud so if I want to run
something on Google Cloud I just hit the
button and it's already there the extra
Cloud workstations
and I'll um to to wrap this up there's
only like one question left and the
question is okay well okay now that
there's this use case in in comments
playing in pdaa and it worked for this
use case you have the csud pipeline
um but how can I set up something like
this for myself and how can I get Cloud
workstations for you and as you see on
the right hand picture of course you can
get a side percent of Excellence yeah
but this is quite
um quite a let's say reserved for
comments bank but the question you
should ask in order to achieve the same
that we did is first what is the reason
what what are you trying to achieve and
our goal was to a enable the developers
and B enable the data scientists
and then the next question is how can
you achieve this so you know no no you
you wish but what do you need for this
do you need your executive sponsorship
do you need your on-prem CSD people do
you need to talk to ml Ops people for
example or who can build a solution who
can write the terraform for this
after you have answered these questions
the next is about process and technology
so um how can you embed
the cloud workstation in your existing
CSD environment you might have a lot of
other stuff running on other platforms
like on-prem or maybe uh even other
completely new environments
and then the question is also are you
allowed to use this new technology you
imagine you need to make sure to talk to
standard Setters you need to make sure
that this regulatory compliant and to
make sure that your also these get some
benefit out of cloud workstations so we
got this mostly because it's Cloud
native it's a managed VM we don't want
to update operating systems Marcus can
do this much better than we can do this
and if you have this this benefit then
then it's much easier to explain why you
you need to use Scout workstations and
last but not least
um he also of course needs to make sure
that you that you talk to the people
because these are the ones the
developers and and data scientists these
are the ones who will use the cloud
workstations in the end so um you need
to make sure that for them it's easy to
get in touch it's easy understandable
why you are having this tool and um in
in the best case you don't need to to
you know convince them but you maybe you
just tell them hey here here's a tool
and then by word of mouth as it happened
in our case in bdaa um the developers
actually approached us to get in touch
with this new technology
so it's uh the same message here
multiple times it's uh of course
processes people and Technology but um
the people is like here the core part
in order to drive the cloud workstation
to to success in your company
so with this being said um this is a
story of Commerce Bank and PDA and Cloud
workstations now handing over back to
macros right thank you so much creates
an exciting story from Commerce Bank and
exciting to have been part having played
a role on that uh story so yeah as you
folks saw
correct stations essentially focuses on
achieving two goals the first one is
increasing develop productivity both on
dev environment setup data development
and it does so by providing optionality
essentially media where they are with
your tools that's one and she was doing
so while you're preserving if not
enhancing your security posture by
essentially bringing all those security
mechanisms you're familiar to with using
on production and moving those your
development environments such as VPC
vpcsc private Ingres and Ingress or
login errors keeper videos available
that was just a is liberal for the have
workstations there's much more but I now
want to also first of all thank you
folks for coming here
thank you